it's incredible to think that these
women have to go from playing in the
olympics and now coming back to their
teams and
and playing the back half of the season
so i thought it'd be a great idea today
to bring on my friend terry jackson
she's the dire executive director
of the wnb pa and a dear friend
appreciate you coming on terry and
walk us through the schedule for the
team usa now that they've won gold what
happens to all these women
as they head back to the wnba hey ben
lyons
thank you for having me on this show
this is great this is great so
yeah so we've been in this hiatus right
we've been on this olympic break
for four or five weeks now it's been
too long for the rest of us um but we
got to see
some amazing women not just team usa
we had like 30 w players in the olympics
team france team spain is crazy so yeah
so everybody's headed back
and well the first thing they're going
to do is probably test
but seriously we're going to get
we're going to get back with play
underway with
the league's kind of new event signature
event called the commissioner's cup
on thursday and then a few days later on
sunday i think
every single team if i'm not mistaken
i think every single team is going to be
back in action
on sunday with a game terry jackson
joins the show
executive director of the wnbpa
and you mentioned the commissioner's cup
this is a new thing and a lot of times
you'll hear rumblings around the nba
that there's talks of a mid-season
tournament as a way to
you know engage the fans or create some
real meaning in the games
where did the idea for the
commissioner's cup come from in the w
and how is it rolling out this year yeah
we need
everybody to tune in it's going to be
streaming on amazon prime i know
the commissioner herself kathy engelbert
is really
pretty excited about this event
it's something really that kind of came
together
probably during negotiations during our
kind of informal negotiations
talk um the players were talking about
how do we jazz up this model
this business model how do we make this
a little bit different a little bit more
fun
for for the fans um you know the league
also i think was looking to develop
additional assets
um the players they you know our players
they go overseas in the off season right
they they you know are playing over in
europe
and there's this kind of out of the euro
leagues is this kind of um
tournament within a tournament so that's
kind of how it all
came together it's like how do we create
another event
um that the players can be bought into
you know be bought in
and and really have fun um the league
could look to market
a tournament within a tournament so this
is the first time that we're we're kind
of going back to the old conference
format um there were you know we have
like 50 60 or so
regular season games there were 10 of
those i believe 10 or 12 of those
regular season games that were
identified as commissioner cup
games so that's when the teams are
playing within their conference
and so the best team out of the eastern
conference the best team
out of the western conference well we
know who that is you know it's the
connecticut sun
and it's the seattle storm they're going
to meet on thursday
in phoenix again streaming on amazon
prime so everybody you know tune in and
watch this
help us really build that that audience
and and
um i think the league's got something
special planned i'm not going to give it
all away i think the league's got
something special
planned for that game so let's watch and
see
terry jackson joins the show executive
director of the wnb
pa and the mother of jaron jackson jr
who i was so proud of on draft night
when he stepped on that stage wearing a
rock the vote jacket
on the inside of his lapel the knicks
would go on to draft kevin knox who had
a fortnight jacket on but we can talk
about something else
jaron's wearing the rock the vote jacket
and the moment that he's getting drafted
how did that come together
what does that mean to you as a parent
your son's got this moment to be drafted
in the nba and he wants to use it to the
fullest of its potential to get the word
out
well first of all let's go back i am the
mother of jaron jackson jr i am the wife
of jaren jackson's senior but you know
we'll talk about junior right now
so um well junior well it's all about
it's all about the jacket on draft site
right it's all about the suits all about
the
jacket and what you're going to do kind
of creative
inside and they just had a few ideas and
one of them was like you know hey mama
you know we're talking about voting the
importance of voting and maybe that's
something i'm going to do when i'm in
the league
you know what what can i do to like kind
of
kick this off on draft night what about
rock the vote
and i was like what are you kidding oh
like
let's call them and see i think we had
like four days
before he had already picked this pink
crush
velvet jacket that he just had to have
period the end nobody was talking him in
or out of that
but we reached out to rock the vote
carolyn dewitt the ceo over there
and said hey you won't believe this but
this is what daryn jackson jr wants to
do what do you guys think what you know
are you behind it can we
can we use your logo can he rock it and
you know um thanks to carolyn she said
yes absolutely
so that's how it all started an
incredible moment uh for your family for
the nba family
uh it's just just remarkable one of my
favorite draft suits of all time
and i bring it up as well because uh you
know when when
nba players speak out about social
issues or
things that are passionate uh to them
it's celebrated it's acknowledged but it
feels like often that the wnba the
players from that league
were already on the on the train they're
already saying these things and we look
to them often
for leadership when the world feels
uneasy or uncertain
talk about some of the great initiatives
you guys are working on i know there's
something going on today
or tomorrow actually that that that you
guys are putting together
that's pretty good yeah thanks for that
ben so when it comes to social justice
issues the players say
it is in their dna and and what i love
about them
then is that they educate themselves
they look to be informed they ask us to
pull together
you know subject matter experts folks in
academia
folks in public health and a variety of
fields
so that they can talk with them so they
can listen and learn and ask questions
coming out of the bubble you know they
talked about black lives matter and and
elizabeth williams
specifically said you know if we're
behind black lives matter then we have
to understand
what that means in the public health
space and so
we put together some educational zooms
around
vaccines around the covid vaccine
we talked history about equity or
inequities in
in public health for black and brown
communities we talked about the ability
to have access
now so um that public health initiative
is really important to them
um what you're talking about um the zoom
that we're going to be doing tomorrow
the panel that we're going to be doing
tomorrow
is in collaboration with two of our
community partners um the black women's
health imperative who's celebrating
their anniversary this week
um the national council of negro women
and cnw
they pulled together a panel called
healthy dose
star-studded panel moderated by angela
rye
um featuring elizabeth williams
to mark my words i'm gonna say i'm just
gonna keep saying this and this this
put it out in the universe elizabeth
williams is going to be the next u.s
surgeon general
one day just just wait and see um she's
going to medical school after she hangs
up her her basketball shoes i'm certain
of that so
but joining elizabeth and angela um
lisa leslie and dr contessa
metcalf do you know that name ben i
don't i don't know
i'm not familiar with dr contestant she
is one of the doctors from married to
medicine
coming out of atlanta so yeah so
we're really excited um about the panel
um it's gonna be so cool so we're hoping
everybody tunes in that is tomorrow
at eight o'clock i think eight o'clock
eastern
it's posted on our instagram so you guys
can uh check it out there but
dr contessa is going to be with us she's
a fan
too she and her family are coming out to
atlanta dream game so she's
she's for real she's for real we're
looking forward to it terry i appreciate
all the work you and the women of the w
are doing on on this u is on this issue
and other issues like you said social
justice obviously top of mind
for the women in the w you have so many
women who are household names
women who are big stars elena schuyler
sabrina asia neca liz
i mean the list goes on stewie you've
been covering the game for a long time
basketball's been a part of your life
for a long time
never seen so many women out there who
are part of the national international
conversation
around the game what are your hopes for
the back half of the wnba season
wow you know what um i'm looking forward
to thursday i'm looking forward to the
commissioner's cup and getting back
underway i'm looking forward to sunday
i like i said so many teams back at it
you know i
these women bring excitement to the game
i mean we thought we were really paying
attention because we were home and
nobody was going anywhere and so we were
watching all these games there were even
more games televised last year than
probably ever before
um so we know the excitement that they
bring
um and they've just got great stories to
tell but the work that we're going to be
doing off the court
not just in public health but around
racial justice and voting rights which
what we'll be doing with the lgbtq
community i'm just so excited because
the players have framed
up you know this this three-part agenda
um working with the community back in it
again
what we know they're capable of doing on
the court we're gonna see our stars
all our stars from the olympics coming
back
um look it is musty tv when it comes to
the w
as long as they put us on tv and as long
as our fans can find it
like no one is disappointed ben no one
is disappointed it's going to be a great
back half of the season
i'm also looking towards um some of the
partnerships that
that the wnb pa will be announcing
um we're we're looking to grow the
business too
and we're looking you know we're just
doing our best we're just doing our best
so
stay tuned there will be more on that
terry i hope with all the excitement
around the wnba for the back half of the
season that the jackson three gets some
time together is that in the cards
yeah so the jackson three you know you
know
ben the jackson three are probably the
only family in basketball
i think i'm right on this the only
family in basketball that can say that
they were in
every bubble last year now we pray that
we
we don't go back to playing in bubbles
ever again but junior was in the nba
bubble i of course was in the wubble
and jay senior was coaching
with the new york knicks g-league team
so he was in their bubble the g-league
bubble last year
we are i'm on the west coast now i'm
going to be headed to
the nba summer league junior's going to
be headed there
probably today tomorrow to support the
grizzlies
uh darren senior is there he's on
the new york knicks summer league
coaching staff
so i will pass through there also of
course the aces are there so i get to
meet with them do their team meeting so
well the jackson three will have some
time in vegas i believe
we might head back to la for a little
bit
but um i look my season is in full swing
i gotta go to work
i gotta go to work the players expect me
um
to be working right now so if i if i can
sneak in a little family time it will be
great
well all the work you do is so inspiring
to us as basketball fans terry i
appreciate you spending some time i know
you're right in the heart of the season
and i do hope the jackson three
can get together in vegas for for at
least a little bit thanks for spending
some time
awesome ben thank you hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here